good morning welcome to the legislative
Administration subcommittee on um
legislative youth advisory Council um
would you please stand up so we could do
the pledge representative Nelson would
you like to leave iedge Alle to the of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all caucus at noon and session starting
at one um today uh we're going to look
at um current law for the lak um the
proposed Bill and uh the changes to the
bill um in in looking through Uh current
law and some of the uh reports that have
been filed um ready for lak um we've
noticed that a lot of times um the
reports were off
topic um we're going to look at the
application process hoping to revamp
that so uh there's a bigger pull to
choose from uh of members we're going to
look at membership and um most
importantly um you know we've noticed
even in testimony that right now um the
committee is operating outside of the
law so we need to uh fix that and uh
make sure we're following the
law um all right
so R popson um would you like to point
out um some issues that you saw that uh
are right now off topic in regards to
the
reporting uh yeah sure thank you um
so trying to find my paperwork well just
going off of the
RSA um legislative youth advisory
council is established to examine issues
of important to youth such as education
employment strategies to increase youth
participation in local and state
government safe environments for youth
substance abuse I'm sorry maybe I don't
need to go through all that but um I I
didn't see uh I I saw a lot
of folks focus on social
issues uh climate change which is not a
problem um but I feel like what they're
tasked with is looking at um issues that
we have statistics on poverty
homelessness homelessness I can't say
that word today for um emotional and
physical health
um
so anyway uh I kind of felt like they
were off topic I didn't see a lot of
reports about that and I don't know if
you have input on that Jody being a yeah
I are these reports like prior reports
that have been thank you for the
question do I have to say that no
committing
okay uh this is my first subcommittee
foral Club committee so I don't know
thank you um I um I do know that in the
past that has been um an issue where um
there were um very partisan committees
um this committee um and um has been
more focused on
um um having a diverse amount of topics
like what you are talking about um to um
research and
discuss um if if you may I can um
actually bring up on my phone the
subcommittees that um these guys are
working with now and I think that you'll
realize that the topics have been
expanded um I agree with you that it
really um going forward we need to
really concentrate on um those types of
issues I so I was thinking of this list
that I just found
um they broke into interest groups
climate action criminal justice
education legislative Administration and
social justice that to me seems outside
of what the RSA indicates they should be
focused on so I don't know if everybody
else has that
opinion just like to point out to the
committee the very first sentence a
legislative youth advisory council is a
established to examine issues of
importance to
youth that's where there should be a
period Then There are
examples the previous statement examine
issues of importance to youth opens the
door for everything under the sun the
others are simply examples it doesn't
lock them into doing that so two years
from now there may be other things they
want to talk about that are happening at
that time in the world the way it's
written right now
they have that
ability um they're not off topic they
simply change the
topics um Mr TBO I saw you raise your
hand would you like to speak to
that um thank you madam chair and
members of the committee um for the
record my name is James TBO I'm the
Youth co-chair of the legislative youth
advisory Council serving alongside
representative Nelson so I just wanted
to say first of all the reports that
you're looking at are a couple years old
those aren't are no longer are well we
call them subcommittees now they're no
longer interest groups um but those are
outdated we have several more this year
that are um and they're more but we're
we treat ourselves as nonpartisan we
don't like getting into partisan
politics but we also um try to focus
more on
um issues that are more unifying is and
there's been a a really heavy Focus this
year on education policy and mental
health as well and other issues of that
nature that are addressed in RSA 19 K1
so I I realize we've been outside of the
statute in the past and that's something
that we've been working to
correct great thank you of
course is there anyone else that would
like to speak to this topic
okay thank you we will make that uh note
to maybe change that uh first sentence
there uh we'd like to talk about the
application
process
um how do we get our pool and how can we
um do a better job at making sure that
uh we're getting a wide variety of
applicants I think that um we have in um
in our bill um some additions that would
be very helpful um we um have asked um
for additional support from um either uh
staff Staffing from the the Senate side
or the house side um to help us develop
a
website to we've also
uh James has also had the idea of um
making it the responsibility of the
Department of AD to disseminate
information about the legislative
advisory Council to all schools and um
um be able to um provide an application
to all schools to spread the word I um
that it has been a challenge for us this
year um we've tried our best to um do
that
um there's work to be done and we think
um you know those two examples and maybe
James can elaborate on that would be
extremely helpful and being able to
provide a bigger app uh a bigger pool of
applicants um we also um have a
challenge and you can talk about this if
you are called upon James um of uh
finding University students and we need
to tap more into our um
university clubs you know um
the university Democrats and University
Republicans um to have a better um pool
to choose from as well do you think it
would be worth um just making it High
School
I do think that it would
be beneficial to reduce the amount of
University
students uh however I do see
um that the University students do
provide a certain level of maturity and
experience that I think is of value to
the entire Council I think that I do
think that it's not a good idea to
completely eliminate college students
and I think the college students also um
feel um that it brings value to them
they're able to um bring um back the
knowledge and experience that they have
um gained through the council to their
school communities um I think that's
very valuable too I do agree though that
um we it's difficult number one to find
College um to fill all of the college
spots and recruiting is difficult it's
you know it's not as easy as asking the
doe to you know disseminate um
information about it so I do agree and
so is the makeup um does it say how many
postsecondary and secondary students uh
yes so you would want to um
lower the postsecondary use I think so
and I think James might be able to
provide a little more info on that yes
James sure so as of right now there's
Provisions made for 12 secondary student
seats and seven um postsecondary student
seats so um in the Amendments that I
emailed to you all before the hearing um
that would be reduced to four and we we
do absolutely believe that they provide
extraordinary value but they are hard to
recruit for because um they just have a
lot busier lives than um we do in high
school but they do provide tremendous
value so um today with us is Rebecca
leak one of our members um who attends
College online with Liberty University
and she um is actually a pre-law student
so she has a lot of experience in this
field already and she has a lot of
knowledge that she brings to the table
that we simply do not have as high
schoolers um so that sort of resource is
incredibly valuable to us and to take
that away I believe would be
shortsighted and um most so I'm in
communication with I believe five other
states legislative youth advisory
councils and that's actually a provision
that I made in the bill is a mandate to
communicate with other states um but um
in talking with them they
seem less focused and they seem to have
less experience because they are mostly
High School groups they're I we are
unique in that we are the only liac in
the country that I'm aware of that has
college students represented and I think
that's incredibly important especially
when addressing education
issues
thank you for taking my question so if
there are no other legislative youth
advisory councils in the state who do
you look to to communicate with you
mentioned just a sentence ago that you
wanted to reach out to other groups in
the country a mandate did you say yeah
man um so there's a mandate in this bill
so it's a as the statute currently reads
it says that we are tasked in our duties
with communicating it says um it just
kind of says other committees it doesn't
really clarify what that means okay but
I've expanded that to say um hang on let
me pull it up yeah so the current
language is communicate with other
councils but I've expanded that to say
communicate with other councils and
committees including but not limited to
House and Senate committees the State
Board of Education the governor's youth
advisory Council on substance misuse and
prevention other New Hampshire youth
advisory councils as formed um and then
other State's youth advisory councils
and that would be RSA 19k three
paragraph
5 okay thank you of course want a
clarification on
that um I also saw that uh you were
thinking of having the Department of
Education be the ones that do um like
reaching out to Public Schools public
charter schools how do you plan to reach
homeschool groups or private religious
schools that's a very uh good point and
I would love to have some ideas from
from you folks if
you uh as far as the private schools for
example Catholic schools and all that
they
still technically come under the deal
so the doe when they send something out
to uh uh public high schools they can
send it out at the same time to uh any
of the private high schools that they're
that they monitor which is should be all
of them the
homeschoolers there's something on the
Internet where they're working back and
forth and talking to doe if I'm not
mistaken I I think you're right just
because um in my experience with um my
children being in public Public School
homeschoolers um are um allowed to join
um extracurricular activities and sports
so there has to be a way that
information is
communicated um we would just have to
find that out for sure so that would
probably all fall under the Department
of Education then okay yeah um the doe
also keeps track of homeschool students
um they have to keep um The Homeschool
parents have to file a letter of intent
and there has to be some goals met along
the way so they actually would have
access to I think to all students in New
Hampshire so did you have something say
James no okay yes right
J back a few moments
ago um you said you're having difficulty
getting college kids I don't know if you
know the answer to this I don't know if
anybody does is there a uh College young
Republicans and young Democrats at say
UNH uh at uh Franklin Pierce uh any of
the other colleges in the State uh sure
I do have connections with the New
Hampshire Federation of college
Republicans I I mean I tend to lean more
conservative myself to be completely
transparent but I'm sure there are other
people on the council that have those
connections with the college Democrats
as well and I would be happy to work
with both groups to try to get that out
reach out because I think it would be
incredibly effective and successful to
do
so what I'm thinking is if uh if those
entities were approached they could
appoint somebody from their own group uh
still go through the application process
and all that but they could appoint
somebody from their group as you know
we'd like this one to be on there and if
you you're proposing to go down to four
post-secondaries if you work to make
sure that it is two and
two from four different colleges or
whatever then fine and
dandy I actually think that's an
interesting idea because I know um I
reached out to the college Republicans
and I think that you did too and did you
or
did um and I mean they're great um and
and and very nice people and um willing
to um you know help out um but I think
if there's buyin to that that they um
would be more willing to be like
cooperative and in trying to find
applicants you know so thank you I think
that's a good
suggestion yes James now would that mean
um that every single College SE would
have to be filled by one of those two
groups because um I I feel like there
should be opportunity for because right
now it adds the provision or the the as
it's currently written in law it can be
anyone um for 15 to 22 who is either in
college or um in the workforce if
they're in the workforce they can't be
represented by college Republicans or
college Democrats or college
yeah that's
a
yeah out to that
yeah or like even career schools as well
because they they wouldn't have because
right now it says um RSA 19 K2 um
postsecondary students or postsecondary
youth May attend a two or four year New
Hampshire College University private
postsecondary career school or other New
Hampshire training or education program
or be a member of the New Hampshire
Workforce and we were looking to expand
that further actually in the Amendments
that I sent out because we have students
like Rebecca who attend online school
with a school that is technically not in
New Hampshire College because she
attends with Liberty University which is
based out of Virginia so technically
she's in like a legal gray area because
she's a New Hampshire student because
she lives here but she doesn't attend a
New Hampshire College to right so she
right now you're currently operating
outside of the law so that's why it's
important to um exactly well we didn't
realize that at the time when she was
appointed by I believe speaker Packard
um we only realize that after the fact
right but that's why we're looking to
make the amendment
absolutely
yeah could we call up Rebecca
absolutely good
morning mson did you want to ask a
question thank good morning I just
wanted to find out uh what brought you
to the legislative youth advisory
Council and um what has your experience
been and do you have any recommendations
as a college student um so I heard about
lak from a friend of mine who he heard
about it from his State reps so um I
honestly almost didn't apply because I
did read the statute and I like I'm not
certain I actually fit into these
categories but I went ahead and applied
anyway and so was appointed um so not
sure what else here how's your
experience been it's been incredible uh
I've learned so much and it's been great
to be able to see more deeply into how
our laws are um written and passed and
been able to have some sort of voice in
that and also been able to meet so many
other young people that I would have
never been able to meet and discuss
issues with
them I had another question for you um
what what value do you believe the
college student perspective
provides um as James said I think uh
college students are a little older so
they do have a little bit more hopefully
a little bit more maturity um like you
said I personally have drawn on my legal
and governmental courses from college in
my um work in lak looking at issues and
discussing issues um so I I do think
they add a good deal to the committee
Council I mean okay thank you
rep Nelson do you find that um you're
unable to fill all the positions right
now or do you have so many applications
that a lot of them aren't even yes we we
are um having difficulty um particularly
again in the postsecondary
applicants so it's just that area uh
James
sure I have a I have a spreadsheet of
all of our vacancies and members as well
as our applicants so for Reference last
year we had 41 applicants this year we
had 12 12 and that was just enough to
fill all of our secondary vacancies
because we had a lot of seniors leaving
last year as well as um students who
kind of went MIA um and there was a
provision in the in the law that says
after three meetings they or three
absences consecutively they are removed
from the council um so we removed them
and replaced them with actual committed
members um and as of right now we
have a um three postsecondary
vacancies and two secondary vacancies um
and a couple of those or the
postsecondary vacancy one of them um is
with the secretary State's office and
that issue has kind of cropped up um
because um his Deputy um informed us
that she would not appoint anyone to the
council who did not go directly to the
Secretary of State's office requesting
appointment so anyone who applies
through our application that we send
them because we solicit and then send
them out um because that's just the most
effective way to go about
advertising um anyone we send she will
she said she will not appoint and so for
that that's why we wanted to have the
application process codified into law is
because then we have one application we
send out all the applications to all of
the app pointers they coordinate with
each other to make the appointments and
then they just get sent out around the
same time and that will make it far more
effective and will prevent stuff like
this from happening where we have
vacancies that we literally can't fill
because they don't want to or they don't
know to go to the Secretary of State's
office rather than um through our
application that we already have
do you think that it would be um better
system if there was the appointments
coming from
one uh like just say what if all the
appointments came from the speaker of
the house yes I think that would be
great if there was one Central um
appointing uh location or person point
person uh to James credit um he um tried
to contact UM
somebody who was um one of The
Originators of the bill to find out what
the intent was um by having the
different um folks appoint um the people
and and he was unable to get an answer
despite his repeated uh requests um so
you know I I think that our intent
wouldn't be to say we don't like your
help and we app we it's not that we
don't appreciate you but the process is
very honorous and very um frustrating um
and James has done a very good T job of
um keeping up and following up with the
various folks that are who are the app
pointers um so but it's difficult and I
agree um having one Central um person do
it so all the applications would go to
the speaker and he would make the
appointments and um I know that there
was some concern that if the
appointments didn't come from different
bodies then maybe you wouldn't have the
access to say this to the senate or to
the governors
but if
um if just the Speaker of the House
handled the
appointments and you would still have
access to those other bodies through
legislation that you're following yes
um yes yes yes um my
only
concern uh and maybe we can address this
um with an amendment is
that our goal this year was to have a
almost as equal of a mix of um political
ideologies as we could because our goal
um one of our personal goals my personal
goal goal and James also shares it is
that we need to facilitate young people
to be able to get together and express
their own opinions and ideas and have
respect for other people's opinions and
ideas and uh I think that's very needed
right now in our um society and if we
can encourage that in a healthy manner
with these young people I think I think
they'll be really great well-rounded
leaders I I'm confident all these I call
them kids I'm sorry guys all these young
people are going to be be really great
leaders so um that would be my only
concern about having one point person
you know um and in the application
process versus an appointment process um
you know we don't you know you can kind
of like discern through you know their
extra curricular activities and um you
know an essay that they might write you
know where where they kind of lean you
know one way or another um it's it
certainly wouldn't be um you know a deal
breaker as to you know why we may or may
not you know think about appointing
someone but that would be my concern um
you know if we have a speaker who wants
to have an entirely partisan I mean one
way or another I'm not picking on you
know Republican or Democrat um group
that that is not going to be
um what the goal of lak should be I
guess is my sure and I would I would
agree with representative Nelson on all
of those points and I would also say
that having multiple app
pointers reduces The Strain on each of
the appointer um because then they don't
have to make all of these different
appointments I mean the speaker of the
house I've been in communication with
his office trying to get a new
appointment made and it's been a couple
months now just because he's so busy I
mean he has like 400 commissions and
committees and councils to appoint to
it's a lot for just him so having it
split up also helps with that and I
think that there is some value to having
multiple app pointers and also the the
partisan mix that can come with that
being you know four different people and
maybe four is too much but I think it
should be like at least maybe the
speaker and the Senate President or
something like that absolutely yes rep
Nelson an idea just popped into my head
um maybe um in order to Aid um the
speaker could be a um a nominating
committee consisting of um one or two
people from um each side of the aisle
that could assist the speaker in
recommending um
applicants or as we're talking about
maybe having the youngest member of the
majority party the youngest member of
the minority party um would they be able
to ass oh yeah yeah yeah they could be
able to parse through that yeah rip tuny
if you want to really keep it simple all
the applicants could be given a number
as their application comes in those
numbers are put into a fishbowl and you
make it real
quick and you
let uh make the
choices very very simple you will get
maybe sometimes you will get a right
leaning viac sometimes you may get a
left leaning one but odds are you're
going to get a
fairly midlin one I don't think that's
very fair because it doesn't um it's not
a merit-based system it's not a system
that accounts for a student who may be
very well experienced and have that sort
of already legislative experience that's
going to contribute to membership on lak
and you might have some kids who are
just in it for the resum building and
who don't actually care getting
appointed and you're absolutely right
and one thing to consider as a
legislator that's exactly what your
constituents will be from all over the
place some will be interested some won't
some will vote their pocket book some
won't that's no offense that's the real
world that's the way it really is and
yes you may want all gung-ho people in
there at the beginning but you also want
the one that sits back every now and
then their light bulb goes off and they
pop up with a very good idea fair enough
you to the fish
approach Nelson did
you
um oh yes did you
have so
um representative McDonald and
representative Williams did you have
anything any input on any of these
subjects that we we just spoke
about wheeler the
work uh not particularly although I'd
say I think it might be a good idea to
have one appointer just because I think
that might streamline the process um and
you know with the appointment system as
it is right now there could be and is a
Republican Senate President a republican
governor and a Republican Speaker of the
House who you know might want to appoint
I mean so I think that concern exists
whether or not there's one appointer or
multiple app pointers um I met Jessica I
came into this thinking you know oh we
should have less postsecondary people on
the committee but after talking to
Rebecca excuse me um I do feel that
postsecondary people have a place on the
committee and and are uh you know could
help the committee in an interesting way
um I guess it's just how we Outreach to
to the schools and and get people to
want to be involved so I i' I'd add you
know getting
people having the council do meetings at
the different schools or getting people
like Valerie and I to go there or
something like that and talk about uh
lak and and what it could do you know
just sort of advertising L and trying to
get people to to know what it is and
want to do it
uh thank you representative Valerie
McDonald Rockingham 25 for the record
and I would have to agree with a lot of
what my colleagues said I think it is
important that the nominations come from
a central place so it can be streamlined
I know there was a mention as a website
and the website could explain exactly
where prospective applicants need to go
whether it's the speaker or another
nominating body I also think there is a
value in the postsecondary members as
one of the members here today has stated
their own value and what they contribute
as a college student and that uh is
unique to New Hampshire as for my
understanding that the other legislative
youth advisory councils in other states
are limited to just high school students
and New Hampshire has benefited from not
having that limitation as far as I am
aware and as for the idea of the
nominating committee to make that
bipartisan I think that there is some
value in that idea as well because as
representative wheer mentioned there is
right now a partisan balance in
leadership and to ensure that this is
not a partisan group because the
intention is to Encompass all youth
viewpoints to really be reflective of
the younger generation that we need to
not have that partisan split so if there
were to be a nominating committee
perhaps with younger legislators I think
we would be both open to that idea and
thank you for asking for our
input thank you
hello I just have a couple questions for
you and before we get started I
just I'm just incredibly impressed by
the two of you when you speak at the
well you are always so
thoughtful and um thank you for serving
because when I was your age the last
thing that I was interested in was what
you are doing and I really I mean I I
think you guys are fabulous so I wanted
to say that first of all um I do think
the idea of having
um young uh representatives from uh you
know one from each side is of value
certainly um I know myself um coming in
as a freshman when I was in my
50s
um with all of my life experience it was
still very overwhelming to be a freshman
so I want this to be a I want it to be a
positive experience for um the
legislative co-chairs as well as the
youth um who are participating in this
Council so um wondering um what your
thoughts would be on how um how the
youth
co-chairs uh the legislative co-chairs
um what your thoughts on managing your
time um and what um support do you think
would be valuable to be provided to you
should you be um the legislative
co-chairs thank you for the question
representative Nelson and I think it is
valuable I know I for one certainly
learn from my more experienced
colleagues every day when I am in the
chamber and to perhaps have someone such
as yourself as the legislative co-chair
in addition to to the two younger
members could be an idea yeah that's
something that we did discuss having
like a tri chair yeah position with the
two youngest and uh like a more seasoned
legislator like U like almost like an
advisory role yeah yeah I think that's
sounds great absolutely yeah I just add
I think it'd be a good thing for the
young legislators Valerie and I were
talking in the representative McDonald
and I were talking in the hall um about
experience and how you know if you're a
young legislator a freshman you don't
often get the chance to chair a
committee or or even one of those
subcommittees you know representative
McDonald and I are uh we are on busy
committees that get a lot of
subcommittees and work sessions and
stuff like
that as freshman as young freshman we
don't always get picked to be the chair
of those subcommittees and I think that
chairing a subcommittee for a freshman
and I've talked to representative Manion
and other people about this um that's an
important educational piece to sort of
understanding the legislative process
and knowing how to hold respect as a
chair and and and do those things so I
think it could be definitely beneficial
for the younger members of the
legislature just as a system in general
to to offer them uh the chance to chair
the lak committee and and get them some
experience and involved in the
legislature more so than than the two of
us already are very good point thank you
you
thank you for taking my question um one
in uh one of the Amendments that's been
proposed it would be not a freshman it
would be a sophomore so somebody at
least in their second term
and do you feel you need it would be
better to have a TR chair or should
there just be somebody who's been uh in
the
house uh for let's say they're on a
fourth term or a fifth term as the
advisor the one who will know uh all the
ways of various Bill moves and what
moves you can't make and what routs
you've got to be to be the advisor and
should that person be a voting member or
just an advisory
member uh you know I think it having an
older member as an advisory member would
be a good thing and and just because uh
it is the liac I think it would be a
good thing to have them as an advisory
member just to make sure things stay on
track that we comply with the RSA as
it's set out um and sort of leaving it
to the young people to uh participate in
the committee itself but having that
sort of crutch there as a fourth or
fifth year term person to rely
on you rip nting Wong did you have
anything to add
um not necessarily um I just saw that
the two youngest members would be on
there and I was a little nervous just
because um you know you're leading a new
group
of people to like through the process
you might not necessarily know what it
is you two are incredibly knowledgeable
but I'm afraid of like the next class
you know like eventually you're going to
get someone who might not be as
knowledgeable or not as willing to go up
to the well to figure out what the
process is um so that was the only thing
that made me nervous but well I I think
if I could in response to that that's
that's kind of my idea around having us
as chairs because you know like you said
we are are involved with the process
we're on two busy committees so we get
sort we've been thrown into the fire um
but as some you know not every younger
member might be thrown into the fire
they might be a working member someone
like that who just sort of is on fishing
game doesn't participate as much I think
this could be a good thing for them if
they were to be that you know younger
freshman because then it sort of gets
them involved in the process gets them
you know they don't have to go up to the
well but they can still speak as chair
they can understand the process of I
think it would level out their anxieties
about being a representative a little
bit more if they were able to chair a
committee like lak that dealt with those
kind of
issues yeah and I definitely understand
the benefit to that member but I'm like
afraid of what the members of the
committee will have to do
not necessarily deal with but if they
don't know when like how a committee
goes because they're just the first
time I think was just my concern but I'm
I'm fine with it either way I'm not
gonna say no just pointing it out I do
think that you have a valid point that
was one thing that I had been uh also um
thinking about
um what happens if the youngest people
um don't want to do it
right and if they feel forced to do it
um is there a way out you know of that
um if I
may perhaps in the statutory language it
could say the youngest member or their
design and that would leave it open if
the member was not willing to at least
from my experience I was unaware that I
was the youngest member prior to
assuming the role so I I could picture
that there would be the next youngest
member thrown into that not realizing
they have another Duty and they may not
be wanting to or unprepared to and in
that case could be a designate I think
the youngest member or should be the
first choice and then if they're
unavailable maybe another person is
appointed in the statute could explain
that as
well or make it the youngest member
willing to
accept versus the youngest member
designate it be youngest me member
willing to accept that would be it but
as far as the other question that
uh you asked concerning the
uh if we didn't have these
two on as the
sophomores um that would be the uh role
then for the advisor to fill in and
guide to folks that let's say just
weren't up to this bar they were at a
slightly lower one to uh take over and
uh handle things until two co-chairs at
that time started to step
up and that's the idea of the TR chair
right well not so much Tri TR chair
chairs with yeah Co co-chairs with an
adviser advisor and
mentor
anything else on this subject yes I just
wanted to um ask and what people's
thoughts were and also give my input on
I know that
um there has been um discussion about um
do we think that a sen the Senate member
the non- voting Senate member is of
value or not of value to this committee
um I would suggest having a senate
member be also in an in an advisory role
I know that one we have spoken as a
group we find Value in having a senator
be in an advisory type of role because
the young people are very interested in
Senate bills as well as house bills and
that person is a valuable source of
information on the bills and when
they're going to be heard and
um so without that piece I think that
this group is um going to be missing an
important piece of the pie of
understanding and being able to provide
input to uh the the entire
process I fully agree with that and
especially since you seem to have now a
uh Senator that is very interested in it
if you can keep that
individual if if that individual would
volunteer for the next uh two years that
would be uh good but yes a senator
should be on
it and I don't think the Senate
President needs to appoint somebody
other
than the Senate member but they don't
have to appoint the kids pardon me but
anybody between 14 and 22 I have
grandchildren that age age they're kids
I'm
sorry no
offense um
I I have I just have to say this is um I
really enjoy the time spent with this
Senator because we're both hockey moms
and there's
a a kinship with another hockey mom that
that's it's hard to find so anyway she's
great I really and and I think she's
she's a very warm individual
um you know
she's uh also a Democrat so I think it's
a good U mix between the two of us you
know
so great um is there anything else that
you two would like to
add no for your thank thank you um James
would you like to
speak sure I just wanted to follow up on
what representative Nelson just said
regarding the part of cens ship aspect
um that's something that I included in
my amendments is that I think there
should be if we have it appointed from
the house um the speaker should appoint
someone from the majority party in the
house and then the Senate President
should appoint someone from the opposite
party and I think it's important to have
that balance because in the past that
hasn't always been the case we've had
two Democrat members and no Republicans
there so having that balance I think is
incredibly important
yeah
question for you you said earlier in
your
testimony that uh you've got vacancies
right now that you haven't been able to
fill yet in your Amendment you're
looking to expand the
size of the commission yes um so I can
question I got for you basically is do
you
need that size 2 to to uh 20 what uh uh
for the younger folks 20 of them uh or
could you've got what I think he said
four vacancies would 16 work would there
be enough people in your opinion for the
discussion to be worthwhile so I will
say that we have applicants for those
positions we're just working through the
process to get them appointed again
session is happening so it's a a lot a
much longer timeline than was pre
session um but um in terms of expanding
the size of the council we are and we
aren't so we're not adding any new
voting members we're adding one member
from the governor's youth advisory
Council on substance misuse and
prevention to act as a liaison between
the two councils because they are they
work a lot more with the executive
branch they don't have the legislative
experience that we do so they would Ben
and I serve on both councils so I know
that they would benefit from the
experience that lak can provide and I
know that lak would provide or would
benefit from a lot of the knowled and
experience on the issue of substance
misuse and prevention that the
governor's Council can provide so that's
more just to ensure that the two
councils can communicate with each other
and in my amendment I also included um
it says any youth advisory Council
established by executive order in case
um whoever the next Governor is decides
to abolish that Council but may create a
new one so it provides that that option
in that that future
proofing excuse
me okay and the liais on that should be
an appointment by the governor since
it's his Council he should do that one
appointment yes and that's um and it
also says elected by the membership of
the council so the governor's Council
can select their own design but then the
governor officially appoints that person
y
can hi it's a little off top well it's
on on topic but it's a little off topic
to exactly what we're speaking about but
um would it be okay if we just um spoke
again about um the college applicants
there are two things that I wanted to
address about that and it also um it's
also pertaining to operating um outside
of the law yes so I think that this um
RSA obviously was written before we had
online school and so I think we need to
make a change um that says you know that
reflects what Rebecca's situation is you
know a New Hampshire
resident um going to school you know
being a um I I think the intent was that
that the kids are here right so they're
not going to be um a student at
Georgetown and only coming here for two
or three meetings right so I think that
was the intent if
you
know of of the originate original
language so we have um I think that we
should um rewrite the language a little
bit to um make somebody in Rebecca's
case you know
legal agreed that should be done but
don't limited to that uh day students uh
I've got no idea how many colleges might
be close to the Vermont New Hampshire
Massachusetts New Hampshire Maine New
Hampshire border but if there are days
students that cross over go to school
there but are home basically every night
they should be able to do it just as
much as the online uh students can
because they're still basically still
living here in the state I think we have
a residency requirement they have to be
residents of New Hampshire yeah that's
what I was
wondering resident res yeah just as just
as long as they're residents of New
Hampshire they can be taking courses
online or over the Border yeah yeah I
agree yes thank you I think that's a
really good point and then also
[Music]
um I don't remember so it wasn't that
important so so in the amendment
language I wrote I wrote um youth
members must be permanent legal
residents of the State of New Hampshire
unless they are attending boarding
school within the state of New Hampshire
during their entire tenure on the
Council in which case they must be
permanent legal residents of the United
States postsecondary youth May attend a
two or fouryear New Hampshire College
University private post-secondary career
school or other New Hampshire training
or education program or be a permanent
legal resident of the State of New
Hampshire either taking College online
college classes with a college based in
another state attending college in a
state contiguous to the state of New
Hampshire or be a member of the New
Hampshire
Workforce
good um section 19 K2 of the amended
version
um you
okay and um James thank you for um you
know as we know um we received this um
bill from OSS that came in a way that we
are not used to um work work with and
James actually did
um did bold and italicize um additions
and I really appreciate the hard work
that he did um to do that that's made it
easier for me and I I've been working
with this bill so I imagine that it's
really difficult for you guys to discern
what's what's new and what's not so
thank you yeah could I just um go into
this topic real quick I'd like to know
um how you identify the lsrs and the
bills of interest um does the whole
committee look you know look over the
lsrs and and see which ones are of
interest to your Council or how do you
go about doing that sure yeah that's
something that we do um do we go through
once the lsrs come out we go through the
list and we just add them to a
spreadsheet and then we just start
following them from there we reach out
to sponsors try to get information on
them as the lsrs come out um but we also
and then of course we determine if we
want to continue to pursue those bills
after the bill text has been released um
because you know an LSR title doesn't
exactly tell you that much um um but so
like we identify okay these are the
issues of Interest this is what we're
going to establish our subcommittees
around based on you know where the
clusters of topics are and then we
determine once the bill text comes out
okay these are the Bills we're actually
going to pursue and so the LSR just kind
of give us a good idea of what our
starting point for the year is going to
be yes I think it's also important to
point out that um each individual on the
council has a say and what they are
interested in so um it's not just one or
two people in the group deciding um each
person gives input on um lsrs and then
bills that they want to um investigate
more um so every person on the committee
has a say on what they're um researching
and giving input on
okay um is there any Merit to um just
doing a broad sweep over L lsrs and then
delve more deeply into them after they
go to the second Branch like because a
lot of times bills go through one body
and they never make it past crossover is
there any Merit in just looking at
things broadly and then really delving
into them when they get to the second
body uh I don't think so I think one of
the things that we focus a lot on in lak
is making recommendations to the
Committees on whether or not we think a
bill should be OTP or itl and ideally I
mean the um you know in theory the they
there that should have some Merit and I
think there's absolutely Merit to the
experience of testifying before a
committee um so I think that if we wait
until crossover I think that strips us
of a lot of what we can do from January
to like April ail which is like nearly
half our Council year so I don't I don't
think there's any Merit to that to be
honest with you thank you thank you
yeah so can you tell me what your
process is to decide what bills to
testify on do you guys take a vote on
particular bills and who decides who
speaks on a bill sure I can walk you
through that um so one um at the
beginning of the year we selected all of
the lsrs we were interested in and then
um we created subcommittees and those
subcommittees meet over Zoom um we
discuss what bills that we like or
dislike and then those subcommittees
vote on um whether or not we want to
recommend those bills OTP or itl and
then those recommendations get drafted
by someone in the subcommittee and then
brought to the entire Council we vote on
the recommendation and if the
recommendation passes then whoever
authors that um statement can um choose
to testify if they want to um and that
of course depends on their own schedule
and if not we can always send someone
else who might be interested but they
don't have to testify and if not we just
send the statement to the committee
chair and the members of the committee
um and um if the or or if the statement
fails we then redraft a new one based on
whatever motion is made in its
place that um how would you decide say
you have a split committee is everything
that you testify on a unanimous decision
ision or um if it's you've got you know
so if it's split um the minority can
choose to write a Minority Report which
will be sent along with the um committee
statement or the council statement um
they don't have to but they can choose
to so if they choose not to then the um
then it goes to the committee without
descent really
um just ask this because it's really
so I saw the testimony come in I also
saw in the statements um a a committee
report or a Minority Report um with your
testimony if there was a Minority Report
would it have come in with that um to
the to the committee which HB 1080 the
statement on that I don't remember which
particular bill it was but I did see a
Minority Report and I'm wondering so
what does the committee at the house get
does it get both of those saw testimony
it should get it should get both um
granted what you have in front of you
like I said is older so and that was at
a time when the council was more
ideologically skewed and I was not in
leadership at the time so I do not know
I do not know exactly what they were
sending to the
Committees yeah of
course this question is basically to the
committee are we drafting an arm sa to
figure out how to get the people onto it
um if there should be any
guidelines uh what their duties
are or are we going to try to
micromanage it and tell them this is how
you will operate because that I don't
think we should do we shouldn't tell
them how to
operate that's what the adviser the
mentor should be somewhat guiding but it
actually actually should be the younger
folks figuring out how the system works
and what the rules are and then proceed
that way without putting it in
statute taken yes I agree um the intent
of our
amendment was really to create a
framework and a guideline to pass the
torch to the next advisory Council um so
there's a consistency and you know we
like we talked about um quite frankly
there was a breakdown in the council and
we really um we really had to have a
period of rebuilding so it it's
important to us to like we said have
this certain
framework um
to set the next Council up for Success
um but I 100% agree with you that's the
way that it is run now um and I would
like to have it continued that way too
thank you for
your yes and to that point I think it is
absolutely the first two it's about
application and it's about creating a
new structure because there is there are
new additions to it um that I think are
very important such as and especially in
the Amendments that I drafted providing
high school credit for um High School
members allowing for or saying
explicitly that the legislative co-chair
will draft um letter of excusal so those
absences don't count against the student
to encourage them to come um staff
assistance from the Speaker of The
house's office or the president of the
Senate um to you know set up video
conferencing or um meeting scheduling or
a website as representative Nelson
alluded to earlier um members of lak on
the State Board of Education many other
states have um students on their state
boards of Education New Hampshire does
not at the moment even though we have a
statutory requirement for students to be
on all the local school boards so this
would be a very easy way to integrate
students onto the State Board of Ed um
and um as well as adding structure in
other ways like explaining what our
annual seminar is supposed to be by
saying it includes a tour of the state
house and guidelines on the uh on
parliamentary procedure that sort of
thing and explaining um the subcommittee
process in legislation um so that they
they um future committees know what to
do um and so this is really a bill
that's just meant to make future chairs
lives easier future members lives easier
and it has the support of the council as
it currently stands as well and that's
why I drafted it with representative
Nelson student members on local school
boards are you saying that's in this one
now or that's currently law that there
have to be oh yeah that's current law
that was passed I believe last year the
year before
um um but yes so every local school
board must have a student member and
that but so this would all this adds is
says that two lak members would serve as
student representatives to the State
Board of head is that an
elected um member or is an a an advisory
member because I won't tell you the
youngest person on our school board but
they're definitely not in high school so
so that in that case
um um just uh I our student
um member on the school board obviously
is a non- voting member they are
appointed by no their school no so no
okay so this is actually something I've
been researching because I'm drafting a
bill on this exact topic right now um
because you know this is what I do with
my free
time um so yeah shocker I know um but
but no um so as it it's currently
written student um government
organizations are are supposed to be the
ones to draft the rules for um students
to elect their student member so but
unfortunately that is very inconsistent
among districts because they just um
don't really care enough they're not
aware of it and the fact that your
school board does not have a student
member means that they are currently in
violation of Statute because they're
probably just not that it's statutory um
so it is supposed to be an elected
member from the um by the students and
it's supposed to be um a non- voting
member as
well since you're knowledgeable on this
okay non-
voting
non-pb in or out non-public out yeah so
it um okay yeah so anything excluded
under RSA 91 A5 they are excluded from
okay yeah um I can give you the statute
or the the RSA real quick I have it up
um hang on um somewhere I've
been RSA
193 nope nope sorry um one 19423
f
of course I have a question um on the
change you made for age requirements yes
uh it currently is um 15 but you want to
bring it down to 14 why is that um there
are a lot of um freshman and younger
sophomores in high school that would be
interested in lak but are currently
excluded so this would widen the net a
little bit and it would give them an
opportunity to get involved at a younger
age and I think that's an incredibly
good thing if they want to
thank
you question not necessarily for you
James but for
us you wanted educ you suggested
education credits for being on
liac I don't think that's within our
purview I think that has to come out of
doe not telling them you must give
credits you can consider it if you think
it fills a
bill so um how it's current so how I
draft the amendment is it says the
office of the commissioner of Education
shall develop a framework to allow for
membership on the council or any other
youth advisory Council under the state
of New Hampshire to be considered for
high school credit and volunteer hours
in public public charter and private
secondary schools including fulfillment
of deific education graduation
requirement so it says it would just
develop a framework to allow for that to
happen that does not mean that the
schools necessarily have to adopt it
although I'm sure that would be
encouraged oh
no yeah
y I
try are there any other
additional information you'd want us
to talk about today so as representative
Tierney pointed out that as the
Amendments I wrote are currently written
I did include sophomore members because
that there was a concern about that
experience piece but we can I I would
honestly after hearing Representatives
wheeler and McDonald speak I would
encourage striking that and making it
just the youngest members or the
youngest willing members um I think that
makes a lot of a lot more sense um and I
would also say that having the um third
advisory member as I also have in this
on in these amendments as I was thinking
about would be very Val valuable um
Senate member absolutely critical um I
would not support striking that and I
would also point out just so everyone is
aware because I feel like there was a
maybe a little bit of confusion earlier
the legislative members do not hold a
vote on lak except currently with
representative Nelson serving as the
legislative co-chair she holds a vote um
and this is in our rules this isn't in
statute she holds a vote only when
there's a tie so she can be a tiebreaker
and that's what we would um and that's
something that we all voted to approve
um in our because it says in the statute
that we can't establish our own rules
beyond the statute okay so the advisor
is the one that breaks the the
tie you're remember yep okay y so she's
the legislative co-chair serving
alongside me as Youth co-chair and how I
currently have it written in this
version of the bill is the majority the
youngest um member from the majority
party would get the tiebreaking vote um
okay yeah all
right okay now I'm having a more senior
moment than you uh I've got to remember
what the heck I wanted to bring up I
disagreed with one of the things you
said there
um
okay
um let
me oh yeah I would also point out that
in both versions of the bill both the
amended version and what's currently
introduced if there are not enough
applications to fill either the
secondary or postsecondary vacancies
then um they can be then members can be
appointed regardless of their
post-secondary or secondary
status okay
Tony can you repeat not what you just
said but what you said in your previous
statement just at the beginning because
that's where I had the regarding the
voting power of of the legislative
members no it was uh that last statement
beforehand I know it was right at the
beginning of it too I said that I
believe I said that representative
Nelson holds a tiebreaking vote in the
case of a tie earlier much earlier it's
generous of you to assume that my memory
is that good earlier we were talking
about dropping the age from 15 to 14 I
think that that was the immediate last
thing I
think problem you didn't
have oh
W oh
gotcha School
wow
um yeah that's how it goes isn't it um
um but I oh yeah there there is one
section so it says um the officers shall
make appointments that Foster Geographic
and socioeconomic diversity that's how
the statute currently reads we struck
socioeconomic and replaced it with
ideological um because you know we can
measure ideological diversity a lot
easier that we can measure socioeconomic
diversity right we don't ask people what
their parents incomes are yeah it was
weird that that was there in the first
place one thing I'd like to add in there
is that a member must come as long as
there are applicants from each
County yeah so we there should be and
that should be in the statute so that
they can't all be no I no offense to
anybody that's south of The Notches
but uh other than when the secret
Secretary of State said hey there's
nobody from the North Country yeah no I
I totally agree and I think there
absolutely needs to be Geographic
diversity in statute and it's I mean it
says it but clarifying that language a
bit more but um I think the big issue is
finding those members and that's where
we're struggling right now so I believe
it was representative wheeler who
mentioned it earlier um the idea of
having um meetings outside of the State
House outside of the lob and trying to
like take it on the road if you and have
meetings in other places and that's
something that we are trying to do for
the rest of this Council year so next
month we're trying to have a public
forum on mental health education and
suicide prevention in schools we're
looking at Pinkerton Academy or St
hansam college for that um but we're
also looking um in the future you know
April May June July having more of those
more North
facing uh as we don't have a budget that
is one of our challenges um one of our
um College folks looked into um UNH
donating a room for that purpose and
they wanted to charge us
$800 so um that is one of our challenges
um we certainly um aren't focusing on um
having a location in Southern New
Hampshire um but um we're looking for a
place that will actually donate room
room space
um suggest talk to Plymouth State yeah
I've and also talk to uh
wmcc up in Berlin White Mountains
Community
College they might they have done it and
if they
don't you might want to ask I don't know
how many folks you get that normally
attend your things but I do know that
um the selectman's meeting room
Groveton has a capacity of 88
people okay uh there's a $25 fee but all
you have to do is ask the
selectman uh to wave that and uh it
generally is done if there's a
legitimate reason um but uh Lancaster uh
theirs I believe can hold way more than
that uh if you get CL groups that are in
the 200 range I believe their U meeting
room is also a theater that they use um
you might be able to ask them and that
moves it into where North country folks
will uh
come visit and talk yeah absolutely we'd
love that and we are trying to get but
you could use those type places also
throughout the state yeah and you're
liable to find that they might be free
yeah that that is incredibly helpful
thank you so much because that is
something we've been struggling with
trying to find places to hold these
meetings because when we hold them at
the L we get nobody and that's not good
for our Outreach so being able to hold
this in other places trying to get more
parts of the state would be incredibly
valuable for us um and so yeah I have
been in touch with PSU um but we our
original thought was UNH and they they
want to charge us $800 plus um
facilities fees Plus Insurance um which
is surprising because I mean granted
this was 10 years ago but we actually
did host lak meetings at UNH and there
was a point um in our like I don't know
when it was repealed but there was rsa1
K5 that said that we had a bank account
and we could accept donations and I
imagine it was for that purpose um to
rent out rooms or what have you but that
got repealed I tried um communicating
with one of the original sponsors of the
lak bill as representative Nelson said
and I could not get in touch with her to
find out exactly why that was
um question
if if this committee for example were to
have a meeting elsewhere or fishing game
let's say uh where they went somewhere
else um are they covered by insurance if
they you know from the state I don't
believe that they can so
um because all of our is that right our
committee meetings have to
be
here Finance
committe hearings in different locations
in the state with the goal of you know
making it moreable to folks who live up
north or whatever it's been in years
past we been
redistricting the redistricting
committee every years they'll what
comms yeah I I I belong to the um
special committee on child care and we
had road trips um we had one in
Manchester uh we had one in Hampton and
another one up
north um so
that's
I
mean the type of insurance
that is the
liability for the build like that not
individually but the
state so I will say that the reason that
UNH wanted us to get the insurance um
was because we will have high schoolers
present and I think it was individual
liability insurance I'm not 100% certain
on that but it I I was told by our
member who was looking into that that it
was specifically because high schoolers
were going to be present thank
you okay we're coming uh to 11:30 are
there any other additional comments that
uh anybody would like to
add no okay um so I'm going to close the
subcommittee hearing for today thank
you